Déclinez votre identité.
Jyn Erso
falsification de document impériaux,
recel d'objets volés,
violences agravés
et refus d'obtempérer.
On peut vous enlever les menottes.
Finissons en s'il vous plaît.
Quand a-tu étais en contact avec ton père pour la dernière fois?
Il semblerait qu'il joue un rôle essentiel dans la conception et la construction de cet arme.
Si c'est mon père qui l'a conçu, il faut qu'on le retrouve!
Que la force soit avec nous.
Ils l'appellent l'étoile de la mort,
une arme épouvantable...
mais on peut la vaincre!
Elle veut se battre.
Moi aussi
Combien il faut qu'on soit?
C'est maintenant qu'il s'agit de se battre!
Chaque jour ils se renforcent...
Allumez-les comme si vous étiez une centaine!
Si il y en a qui ne veulent pas risquer d'être à la traîne,
c'est le moment de vous exprimer!
[K2-SO] : C'est une très mauvaise idée...
[Cassian] : Hé, silence
Rogue one